[музыка]
Вам столик на одного.
>> Секундочку. А он не один. У него есть
счёт в точкобанке и круглосуточная
поддержка.
>> Счёт и бухгалтерия для бизнеса
бесплатно. Бизнесу быыть.Нан.
Кого нельзя брать на работу?
Меня.
мальчика, который
>> Меня не надо брать на Я очень плохой
работник. Вот меня я бы никогда в жизни
не нанял на работу.
>> Не женат, у которого нет,
>> который не женат. Так
>> и который из кореной из Барнаула я на
работу не возьму.
>> Блин, Барнаул тут причём?
[смех]
Почему Барнаул? Чем Барнаул-то недил? Ну
точно
>> такой автопортрет состо.
>> Да этому говнюку
>> он ещё и говнюк.
Когда выступаешь в паблике, надо
фильтровать база.
>> Есть куда отступать, он будет бегать по
всему Барнау и так далее. А вот
мальчику, который переехал сюда из
деревни, ещё и был единственный сын и не
было отца. Если ему 30 лет, на самом-то
деле, ещё даже если были родители, ну,
есть родители, но,
>> короче, он хочет тебе не сотрудника, а
раба. Вот всё, что он говорит. Я хочу,
чтобы у меня сотрудник в лютой был
нужде, в страшной зависимости, со
ошпаренной жопой и страдал. Вот тогда он
типа хороший работник. Мужик, у меня для
тебя плохие новости. Да, наверное, нужда
и
побуждает людей работать, но она их
побуждает выживать и работать минимально
возможное, необходимое. А если ты хочешь
полететь на Марс, тебе нужны люди, люди,
которых мотивирует желание, стремление,
а не нужда. И я не знаю, какой бизнес у
этого мужика, что он рассуждает и чем
он, собственно, занимается, но,
наверное, если он работает на стройке,
ему нужны эти, не знаю, копатели канав,
жена,
>> хороший план.
>> А вот такой мальчика я возьму. Ему уже
есть за ко
>> ещё у меня вопрос. Он девочек собирается
брать на работу или его только мальчики
интересуют?
>> Вы отвечаете и так далее.
>> Не только смотрим на портфолио, не
только смотрим на то, где поработал, а
смотрим и на личное качества. А это не
личные качества. Они говорят не про
личное качество, они говорят про
жизненные обстоятельства.
>> О, я нашёл сироту без жилья и без денег
из другой страны. Отнял у него паспорт,
и теперь он хорошо работает. Вот он что
говорит.
>> Ну блин, мужик, это плохая идея.
>> А может ты просто не можешь мотивировать
людей? Может с тобой не интересно? Может
работу, которую ты предлагаешь, никого
не вдохновляет, не мотивирует. Работать
можно только потому, что тебя, [__]
[__] вообще. Просто вообще жить негде.
А чем ты предлага? А что за работа?
[фыркает] А на этой работе можно
работать не вот не по нужде, не чтобы
тебя заставляли жизнь, обстоятельства
или кто-то ещё.
Чем не занимаются? Я не знаю. Просто
>> я пришла за последний год. Это ценности.
Это,
>> [__] ещё и 2 минуты.
>> Личное качество.
>> Эта штука называется социальная икария.
А
>> у человека есть социальные яка?
>> Название придумал какое-то. Социальный
якаря.
В общей сложности вот профессиональный
чар, он отслеживает 19 только базовых
социальных якарей.
>> Пошла вот эта наука ёмная [__] вот это
вот социальные якаря 19 базовых. Учёные
доказали всё.
А [откашливается]
какие 19? Почему 19? Он их перечислится.
Я не знаю.
>> Если хотя бы, грубо говоря, четыре-пять
из них есть вероятность того, что и в
человека можно вкладываться. Ну,
допустим, как ни странно, один из
социальных икарей, вот он вроде бы
простенький, но он эффективненький. Вот
при всех прочих равных условиях женщина
выберет место работы, которая в пределы,
грубо говоря, там 20 минут пешком от её
квартиры.
>> Всех женщин одну гребёнку закатал.
Всё, конечно. [тяжело вздыхает]
Ой, мальчики, женщины 20 минут,
люди сложнее. С людьми так нельзя.
Мотивация людей намного сложнее. И самых
больших высот и результатов достигают
люди не потому, что у них нужда и 20
минут до работы, а потому, что у них
жгучее желание и суперцель.
На Марс по нужде не летают.
>> Она ориентирована, да, удобство и при
всех
>> удобство.
>> И на Луну из удобства не летают. Они,
[__] неделю в памперсах сидят в на 2
квадратных м² втроём.
Это неудобно.
>> В прочих равных условиях чер сразу
скажет: "Ага, вот это живёт рядом, уже
рассматриваем". Второе, допустим, есть,
допустим, там ребёнок руководство, как
нанять себе очень хуёвую команду
немотивированных людей, которые будут
работать и ненавидеть свою работу.
[тяжело вздыхает]
Отличный [музыка] план. 5 и 8 лет уже
болеют, меньше и так далее. У, совсем
рассматриваем.
>> Просто такое ощущение, что он лошадей
каких-то забирает детей. Там будет 5,8
или
а
>> вот с мужем, да, замужем и так далее.
>> Здесь читается какой-то прежде всего вот
что меня дико бомбит, что он как-то
разговаривает про про людей, как будто
это не люди, как будто ей богу, он себе
подбирает
лошадь тяговую.
Да, всё, блин, сложнее. Всё с людьми
намного сложнее,
особенно с хорошими, творческими,
созидательными, талантливыми людьми
намного, намного сложнее.
Далее. Ну, живут в одну ушке.
>> Это значит точно, ну, копят на что?
>> На расширение, на квартиру уже совсем
рассматриваем. А ещё у неё есть на
самом-то деле старенькая машина. А мы на
самом-то деле, если ей будем доплачивать
на самом-то деле,
>> а если у неё Mustang шестьдесят девятого
года,
ну и там ещё Mercedes Gдвин
[смех] старенькая же
>> за мелкий ремонт и нормативным способом
там у неё ремонт этой машина стоит
дороже, чем твоя контора.
>> Гасить затраты на ГСМ совсем
рассматривать. Вот когда она вот так он
таких нищих клей ищет, чтобы
что это за люди, кого он хочет нанять,
что затраты на ГСМ являются это
критичным.
Тут надо ещё понимать, что у всех
работодателей, у всех вот этих вот
теоретиков, и у меня в том числе
разное представление о людях и о
работниках, потому что разные работники,
разные бизнесы. Одно дело,
действительно, я стройкой руковожу, у
меня 4.000 там монолитчиков. Другое
дело, я руковожу архитектурном бюро, у
меня 100 архитекторов или у меня
программисты. А может быть, это я всё
время всем рассказываю, я помню в
качестве примера, говорю, представляете,
у вас бизнес называется Universal Music,
и ваш сотрудник - это Мадонна.
Что он Мадонна будет? Гово, что далеко я
от дома ездить? Вот. [смех] А как бы он
рассуждал, если твой сотрудник это, не
знаю, Ричард Гир? Ну, бывают такие же
сотрудники, да? А с Том Крузом как надо
это понужде. Смотри, ГСМ. Сколько Том
Круз тратит на ГСМ в месяц? Что-то
как-то вот. А машинка у него старенькая.
Кстати, у него
>> тут рассмотрит, она выберет девочку,
которую в которую можно вкладываться, с
которой можно работать.
>> И вот это пренебрежение. Мальчик,
девочка, ты кто такой, [__] Мальчик,
девочка?
Я бы к нему точно никогда не пошёл на
работу. Я не хочу, чтобы кто-то со мной
даже так разговаривал, блин.
>> Которыю можно учить. И когда ты возьм?
>> Жаль, я не из Барнаула. Есть шанс к
такому влететь. Мёш двадцатипятилетнюю
свистушку.
Свистушка, [__] просто прослушаешь. Ты
охуел, что ли? Свистушка, [смех] [__]
ты что так о людях разговариваешь?
[фыркает]
А ещё лучше 22 года, которая основная
задача просто у неё ужас от того, что
она ещё не вышла замуж, блин. У которой
есть своя квартира. Родители купили
хорошую машину. Вы что, серьёз думаете,
что вот
>> хотел бы я на его дочь посмотреть?
>> Вот эта зайка, даже если она будет
разделять ваши ценности, она у вас долго
и качественно будет работать.
>> Ужас, ужас, кошмар.
Я всё, я кончил.
[смех]
>> Ты каких людей нанимаешь на работу? Есть
у тебя вообще какой-то вот этот
личностный ценс? Такого беру, ского не
беру. [фыркает]
>> Я стараюсь занимать людей на работу,
которых не надо заставлять работать,
которые сами хотят работать, у которых
есть собственный драйв, движ, желание
жгучее, сделать свою работу хорошо и
стать лучше. И я не думаю, что мы должны
людей мотивировать нуждой и затратами на
ГСМ. Это это [__]
Но мне нужны творческие люди, мне нужны
программисты, разработчики, дизайнеры,
менеджеры, поэтому в моём случае такое
не работает. Ну и самое главное,
[фыркает] ээ
мы не можем называть людей ни девочка,
ни мальчик, ни свистушка.
Я даже стараюсь не использовать слово
сотрудники, если вы не обратили
внимание. Я сде говорю люди.
Мне меня коробят даже от слова кадры.
Ээ, поэтому
и вы знаете, в этих словах кроется
многое. Э-э, мне кажется, что база в
тровых отношениях - это уважение. Вы
должны уважать, ээ, человек с работника.
Работник должен уважать вас. Ээ если вы
начинаете разговаривать с ними мальчик,
девочка, свистушка, но они точно не
будут вас уважать. Да, наверное,
конечно, если ты будешь вот так вот
отталкиваться от нужды и от э-э
жизненных обстоятельств людей, опираться
на них, эксплуатировать эти
обстоятельства, да, он же говорит про
это. Он говорит: "Я найду человека, у
которого тяжёлая судьба, тяжёлая жизнь,
и буду это эксплуатировать".
[смех] Ну, наверное, ты заставишь этих
людей закрыть какие-то производственные
задачи, но ты точно не получишь людей
мотивированных, которые хотят, не знаю,
сделать в 100 раз больше. Ну да, ну я не
знаю, что это за бизнес. Я не знаю. Я
ничего не знаю про этого человека,
извините. Я не знаю, каким бизнесом он
занимается. Я, может быть, сейчас
какую-то гадость про него сказал, он на
меня обидится, но мне не нравится, как
он говорит и что он говорит. Это вот
точно
>> топ-пять бизнесов, [музыка] которые
выживают всегда. Сохраняй. Это поможет
тебе.
>> Отвод сточных вод, электроснабжение,
тепло, энергоносители.
Они всегда выживают,
не сомневайтесь. стартануть, когда
решишь, [музыка] да? Первое, самое
главное - это еда, производство,
продажа, доставка. Люди могут
>> вообще ни хрена подобного, кстати.
>> Могут экономить абсолютно на всём,
[музыка] кроме еды.
>> Ничего подобного. Как раз люди могут
экономить на еде. И мы это видели в
девяностых, когда они жрали с огорода и
ни хрена не покупали, а растили свою
картошку сами. Еда очень плохой бизнес,
потому что он очень конкурентное. Причём
конкурентный конкуренция бесконечная. Ты
можешь конкурировать с огородом,
с трудом. То есть человек может
вырастить свою еду сам и может сам себя
в теории прокормить. Более того, человек
может постоянно упрощать свои пищевые
привычки. Он может перестать есть
говядину, начать есть свину, перестать
есть свину, начать есть птицу там и так
далее. Вообще отказаться от белка.
Поэтому нет, нет, нет. [смех] И более
того, чем мы будем спусаться к более
базовые детя, тем будет ниже
маржинальность.
Нет, еда очень неплохой бизнес в кризис.
Второе - это ремонт. [музыка] Да,
бытово.
>> Вы что, охренели? [фыркает]
Ещё один очень плохой бизнес-кризис,
потому что можно нихера не
ремонтировать.
А он говорит про ремонт по нужде, когда
у меня сломался телефон, я вёл ещё
купить новый телефон, ремонтирую старый.
Там будет такая кровавая баня. Кто будет
делать на 20 руб. дешевле, будет
забирать клиента.
Хороший бизнес. Это не когда мы топим
космос и оплачиваем это из своего
кармана. Хороший бизнес. Когда мы
маржинальный бизнес,
ремонт по нужде супернизкомаржинальный
бизнес со сверхконкуренцией.
Там нет денег.
Будете очень мало зарабатывать и умрёте.
Ой, строительный [музыка] автосервис.
Да, кризис - это время чинить, не время
покупать новое. Ты же знаешь.
>> И кроить, кроить, и кроить.
[музыка] Третье - это транспорт и
логистика. Пока едут,
>> [__]
Первое, что страдает при падении
экономики - это транспорт и логистика.
Потому что транспорт и логистика - это
прямая функция ВВП. Есть даже такая
методика оценивать экономический рост по
спросу на грузоперевозки.
Одна из объективных метрик состояния
российской экономики - это
грузоперевозки по железной дороге. Они
растут, значит, в экономике всё хорошо,
они падают, в экономике всё плохо.
Транспорт и логистика - это прямая
корреляция с экономической состоянием в
стране. Соответственно, если кризис,
что будет с транспортом и логистикой,
она упадёт.
Грузы.
>> Я жду ещё две классные идеи.
>> Деньги всегда крутятся, [музыка] да?
Четвёртое - это упаковка. Всё,
>> ёпты.
[смех] Это четвёртое, что умрёт в
кризис. Пото чём сэкономит, это на
упаковке.
Вы что, издеваетесь?
Ой. Ададада. Пятый. Пятый будет
>> то, что нужно хранить, возить, [музыка]
продавать. Нужно как-то паковать. Да и
пятое.
>> Нет, бывает многоразовая упаковка,
[смех]
это овосько вместо пакета.
Ой,
>> последнее - это агра и фермерство. Кто
вы?
>> Ёпты, [фыркает]
он не подвёл.
Фермерство и агро.
супернизкомаржинальный
бизнес с большими капиталовложениями
и с мировой конкуренцией.
Ещё одна проблема агрофермерского
бизнеса. Ты постоянно конкурируешь даже
не со своим соседом, а с фермером из
другой страны. Поэтому фермеров везде
постоянно пытаются защищать.
А у нас есть проблема.
Погода у нас плохая погода. Никому не
говорите.
Это в Бразилии четыре урожая помидоров.
Это тайна. Никто этого не знает. [смех]
А в Чили пять урожаев картошки.
[фыркает]
Мы херово конкурируем сельхозпродукцией.
У нас не растёт полгода нихера, [смех]
понимаешь?
А чтобы помидоры выросли, их надо топить
в теплицах. Там дорого.
>> [смех]
>> Худший бизнес, которым можно заниматься.
[__] на севере
это фермерство, [смех]
понимаешь, [__] [фыркает]
Ой, не могу.
Ой,
ну
ладно. [фыркает]
>> Вытащивают еду, тут зарабатывает. [смех]
>> Ну там всё, в общем. А, ну, а есть
всё-таки какие-то варианты для малых
бизнесов выжить в кризис? Что, что
делать-то?
>> Ну, так нельзя. Ну, вопрос, какие у тебя
ресурсы, какие у тебя компетенции, в
какой позиции ты находишься.
Самая главная мысль мне очень
понравилась,
что если ты не монополист, если твоя
рыночная доля в любой нише менее там
15%,
тебе вообще на макроэкономику наплевать.
Даже если рынок уменьшен на 20%, это
кошмар, катастрофа, кровавая баня. Ты
можешь вырасти в два раза при этом
просто за счёт других игроков на рынке.
Более того, кризис замечательное время
для тех, кто эффективен и маржинален на
фоне своих конкурентов, потому что при
падении рынка твои менее маржинальные,
менее эффективные конкуренты будут
умирать и освобождать тебе поляну.
>> Поэтому, если, например, у тебя очень
высокая маржа и эффективность, кризис
для тебя - это супер время, потому что
будет вымывать твоих неэффективных
конкурентов, и ты будешь забирать их
долю, и ты можешь за счёт этого отлично
расти.
Как говорил Бафет, кризис - это время,
когда видно, кто купался без трусов.
Соответственно, если вы эффективны и
маржинальны, кризис - это лучший период
для вашего бизнеса.
Если ваши конкуренты неэффективны и не
маржинальные, да, если они тоже
эффективные, маржинальные, ну, блин,
проблема. Поэтому что за бизнес, какие
условия, что ты умеешь в этом бизнесе,
где ты находишься? Ну, нельзя так
огульно давать советы, но вот это просто
фундаментальная [__] Все пять идей
полная шляпа.
>> Бренды закрываются, называется видео.
>> Российские бренды закрываются один за
одним, но никто не объясняет, почему и
что делать. Мировые бренды держатся,
потому что встроены в жизнь людей через
>> Как только начинается утверждение:
бренды закрываются, рестораны
банкротятся, всё сразу будет дальше
булшит, можете дальше не смотреть. Ну
это слишком голословно, но так нельзя.
Какие бренды? Почему? А какой процент?
Вот сейчас был рестораны закрываются, за
январь закрылось 340 ресторанов. А это
много или мало? А сколько открылось? А
сколько закрылось в прошлом январе? А в
прошлом оказывается закрылось 335.
На шесть больше, чем в прошлом году. Это
выглядит как катастрофа.
Короче, любое голословное утверждение в
духе: бренда закрываются. Можете видео,
в принципе, закрывать. Скорее всего,
булшит, но мы посмотрим. субкультуры,
спорт, музыку и тому [музыка] подобное.
Большинство российских продают вещи, но
не продают смысла идей.
>> Да ну
вот тупые все такие. Один ты умный.
[фыркает]
>> Не транслируют свою [музыка] позицию или
образ жизни. Сложно.
>> Что это?
Все только этим занимаются. Вообще любой
бренд только этим и занимается.
Причём
Газпром сочиняе мечты. Так там так было,
например. А это что по-вашему? Он же не
пишет рекламу. Мы продаём газ под 5 руб.
6 коп за кубометр.
[фыркает] Так выглядит реклама Газпрома.
Она выглядит по-другому.
20 лет назад-то было, я помню.
>> Экономика, сложная погода в сезон, но
есть и [музыка] объективная реальность.
которые российские бренды одежды не
могут.
>> А про одежду
>> я не понял. [фыркает]
>> Создать [музыка] бренд одежды, а создают
только его фасад.
>> Что это? [смех]
Что это? Только все этим и занимаются.
>> Если я не прав, размотайте меня [музыка]
в комментах, буду рад. У
>> а что тут разматывать? [смех]
Типа вы знаете, все россиские бренды
[__] Ну что я не прав, размотайте меня
в комментах.
>> Ты говоришь, э, папа, а что разматывать?
Не, [__]
Нет, ты не прав. Всё, мы тебя размотали.
Всё, пошли домой. Всё. Там аргументы
были какие-то? Никаких. Что тут
разматывать?
Нет.
Все бренды во всём мире всегда только
этим и занимаются.
И
да, наверное, если это очень маленькая
компания, она делает это плохо, неумела,
просто сила отсутствия компетенции, но
любая маломальски
развитая контора будет только этим и
заниматься. Особенно, блин, в одежде.
Где ещё, если не в одежде?
И нет, российские бренды ничем личаются.
А потом он, когда говорит про западные
бренды, которыми он восхищается, он про
какие западные? Про бразильские.
Может быть, про индонезийские.
Он каки про какой Запад нам говорит?
Чувак, назови пять немецких брендов
одежды. Что, не можешь?
Их там нет, по-твоему?
Он же берёт Top of the Top. Он же
говорит: "Ну вот есть Nike, у них всё
охуенно". И есть вот наши русские все
[__] Сравнил [смех] Найки и русских
всех.
Он так что ли делает? Или он говорит:
"Вот, вот есть бренд хороший такой на
Западе Луи Витон".
А у нас что-то [__] всё какое-то,
кирплатинина какая-то.
Но у нас есть хорошие, сильные,
локальные бренды. Они всё делают
правильно, потихонечку растут, учатся.
Может быть, кто-то из них станет и
глобальным. По-моему, даже кто-то
становился. Я сейчас могу наврать.
>> А кто тебе симпатичен из-за российских
локальных?
>> Ты меня про бренд отдель спрашиваешь?
Да. как главного модника Ютуба.
>> Я большой специалист по брендам одежды.
Да, я, да, по мне видно.
Да нет, я очень плохо разбираюсь в
отечественных брендах одежды. Ну, мне
хватает ума не сравнивать этут
Зарину с Найки. Да, ну я что-то понимаю
немножко, да, что тут как бы немножко
про разное мы говорим.
И надо понимать, что действительно
российского люкса мало, потому что люкс
может быть только глобальный.
А в массомаркете свои законы жанра, там
свои УТП, свои ценности.
И мне так кажется, насколько я понимаю,
в массовом сегменте у нас всё неплохо в
низком, да, и там доминируют российские
бренды. Может быть, они доминируют не за
счёт там какого-то месседжа, а за счёт
дистрибуции локации. Ну так у Зары тоже
месседжа нет,
да? Один из самых, если не самый
успешный бренд мировой одежды Зара, у
него месседж, типа, мы делаем копии
дешевле и доступней. Я вам напомню
изначально,
>> какой ещё меседж
>> у Зары? Чем отличается от наших компаний
и чем конкурирует Зара?
Да, вроде как нет. Она делает хорошую,
доступную одежду мирового уровня в
ближайшем магазине.
И это замечательный кейс, по-моему. Я
так понимаю, компания Index, да, она из
самых больших компаний в мире, одна из
самых успешных.
>> А в целом, если широко за фшн выйти, кто
тебе по брендингу и по
>> А я много раз говорил, я обалдею от
Уазика как бренда, от KGB,
наш лучший бренд, водка столичная. У нас
есть огромное количество очень успешных
брендов. Самый успешный сегодня KGB
100%.
Что это?
>> КБК.
[смех]
>> Мы там вообще такое вытворяем на
планете. Ну, если послушать западные
медиа, мы прямо вообще просто и сразу
вот инопланетяне, а потом мы. [смех]
Это сильная история, которую объективно
можно эксплуатировать. Я думаю, что
запросто можно выпустить какие-нибудь
шпионские товары
и позиционировать, что это русская
шпионская техника.
продавать где-нибудь в Бразилии.
[фыркает]
>> А есть ли
>> какие-нибудь GPS-трекеры?
>> Слушай, а есть ли корреляция между тем?
Просто хотел тебя спросить. Есть же ещё
один бренд Великие русские хакеры.
Ну такой,
>> ну ты же оперы. Вот эта стезя. Ну
сейчас, кстати, неплохо её отрабатывают
наши инфобезопасники
всякие. Позитив там. Они неплохо сейчас
торгуют по всему миру. Вот именно этим.
Просто это обывателю не видно. Обыватель
этого не понимает. А там у нас неплохой
бренд, вполне себе мировой, хороший.
Калашников. Охрененный бренд, да? Почему
мы его не монетизируем? Мы просто очень
плохо это всё монетизируем. Мы не умеем
на этом зарабатывать
объективно. Но у нас есть огромное
количество мировых супербрендов. Ээ, и
если мы выходим за рамки одежды, хотя и
в одежде там шапка ушанка, что мы её не
эксплуатируем,
что мы не доиграли с этими платками
нашими какими-то. Там тоже был потенциал
неплохой. Сейчас вот
что-то пытаются, но,
короче говоря, у нас есть бренды,
которые сложились органически,
исторически и,
в общем, есть чем гордиться. Если
хотите, чтобы я прокомментировал
какой-то ролик или, может быть, ваш
ролик, присылайте комменты Telegram,
куда-нибудь обязательно всех
откомментируем.
[смех]
[музыка]